oh I you know I the one of the spaces
I'm really watching very carefully is
the mobile space and I think that for a
long time innovation on the mobile
platform was held back behind the
carriers and their control over
everything and they're sort of passion
to control everything now that we're
getting some brands of phones that are
consumer brands that are popular enough
that we're starting to get the correct
kind of separation of you know people
say I want an iphone or I want a google
phone an android phone right people
start to say those kinds of things and
those are the those are the brands they
want and the carrier is just whoever you
give service from and if we can break
that that that control that the carriers
have had over the platform then we get
the same kind of innovation that we had
on computers on the internet people can
be building apps and doing all kinds of
crazy things and I don't know what's
going to come out with that I just know
that when you when you put together a
platform that people can innovate on
interesting things end up happening
you